un tonner d'applaudissement pour
Jean-Marc
[Musique]
Généreux merci Simon
merci on va danser on va tous se lever
parce que danser ainsi c'est moche ah
j'ai j'ai j'ai tellement l'énergie de
frère Baudoin ah j'ai l'énergie de frère
Baudoin là là je sens s'il y a quelqu'un
qui ne bouge
pas c'est du flan ce n'est que du flan
on a fait la fête et c'était très très
drôle de se retrouver dans le réfectoire
et qu'on pouvait parler
etchanger je pense que j'ai parlé
beaucoup peut-être même un peu trop mais
bon bref on s'est amusé tout le monde a
a participer à la fête de sa façoni j'ai
fait danser des gens faut bouger le
poupoué mesdames et messieurs
[Applaudissements]
là est-ce que vous êtes prêts
oui 5 6 7 8